vi ricordate questa locandina era una
macchina super veloce che portava i
protagonisti in giro nel tempo a spasso
nel tempo però in questo display
digitale che avevano nel loro cruscotto
di questa macchina incredibile a un
certo punto spuntava la data del 21
ottobre 2015 ed eccoci qua
nel futuro era qualche mese fa io sono
un osservatore di questo futuro da un
punto di vista privilegiato
certo non ho viaggiato nel tempo questo
ve lo devo dire anche perché caso e
autovelox queste macchine troppo veloci
farebbero più danni che altro
però questo posto privilegiato e questo
anzi questo posto nel 2010 un mio amico
andrea bartoli e florinda sajeva sua
moglie hanno deciso di trasferirsi in
questo posto avevano a disposizione un
sacco di mete dove poter far crescere i
propri figli
però in questo futuristico 2015 dove nel
film si prevedevano skateboard volanti
scarpe autoallaccianti ologrammi di
certo in questo luogo era un po
difficile no entrerà in questa
prospettiva però loro hanno deciso di
investire il loro tempo aprire aprirsi
ascoltare alle migliori menti del
territorio oggi questo posto e così in
questo posto ci sono shop ristoranti
luoghi di incontro con working è però
non è che voglio parlare di questo
perché se ci fermiamo solamente a questo
modo di poter rivedere un luogo che può
essere simile ai centri storici delle
città dove viviamo potremo vedere
soltanto l'un per cento di questo 2015
però me lo voglio raccontare attraverso
due storie la prima è quella che vede
protagonista un papillon un cravattino
anzi sono tanti questi frattini questi
papiano perché carmelo è un appassionato
di vintage e appassionato di moda e sua
mamma sarta sono antichi mestieri che
magari poco
hanno a che fare con il futuro però lui
ha cominciato a fare interagire
l'analogico con il digitale e dunque
attraverso questo posto questi luoghi
dove transita in un sacco di persone ha
cominciato a creare questi papillon a
venderli in questo posto dove
cominciavano ad entrare un sacco di
turisti finché arriva una ragazza
australiana che si innamora dello stile
di carmelo acquista questi papillon si
riporta nella sua terra e durante il suo
matrimonio li fa indossare al suo sposo
e testimoni vengono fotografati e da lì
esplode tutto perché una rivista molto
importante di moda a livello
internazionale si interessa di questo
modo di vestire di questo stile italiano
e carmela prendo il suo negozio online
oggi vive del suo lavoro
a favara al sud del sud cioè dove esiste
oggi farm cultural park non è facile
assolutamente non è facile perché noi in
fin dei conti abitiamo nelle città dello
0 a 0
ve lo spiego meglio annibale è una
persona che io stimo molto è un
dirigente della pubblica amministrazione
e lui durante un'intervista dei giovani
pugliesi dove appunto cercavano di
indirizzare le politiche giovanili del
suo ente ha chiesto ragazzo come
interpreti la tua città
le disse una cosa che sbalordì un po
tutti ovvero io vivo nella città dello
zero a zero nel senso che quando
qualcuno fa un gol ovvero fa qualcosa di
buono no che quindi fa sviluppare la
società verso un qualche cosa
tutti gli altri invece di andare a
segnare un altro gol e quindi migliorare
ancor di più il contesto dove vivono
corno dall'arbitro per far annullare il
gol ha appena assegnato
quante di queste cose accadono nella
società
e ancora se questi ragazzi avessero
voluto entrare nel mondo del lavoro
quasi sicuramente avrebbero trovato un
qualcuno che dice sì ho necessità di
nuova figura professionale all'interno
della mia azienda però mi deve dare
esperienza ma come faccia a faccia darti
esperienza se non mi fa entrare nel
mondo del lavoro e dunque quello
definito quella vita che si avvita su se
stessa che non ci permette mai di uscire
fuori far vedere quanto siamo capaci di
poter fare qualche cosa
e arriviamo alla seconda storia che vede
protagonista questa volta un agendina
davide è laureato in conservazione dei
beni culturali in una nazione come
l'italia che ha tantissimi beni
culturali tantissimi siti unesco
potrebbe essere molto facile entrare nel
mondo del lavoro
invece non è così quindi lui è un
disoccupato rimane sempre in questo
contesto a favara però si ricorda di una
materia che aveva studiato aveva
appassionato che era una materia che
riprendeva e studiava come venivano
relegati gli antichi codici antichi
libri allora lui dice io voglio
applicare questa stessa tecnica su delle
agendine che poi voglio vendere in
questo posto che oggi vede tantissimi
turisti circa 40 mila turisti che
decidono di andare per queste vie di
questa cittadina al sud del sud e anche
lui come carmelo riesce oggi a vivere
del proprio lavoro facendo un'altra
volta incastrare l'analogico il digitale
quindi permettendo di vivere questa
quarta rivoluzione industriale che
stiamo vivendo tutti quanti che permette
a tutti i quadri di potersi esprimere se
sanno utilizzare i mezzi che hanno a
disposizione ma torniamo a farm perché
che cosa sarebbe accaduto se questi
ragazzi non avessero avuto un luogo
delle persone che avessero detto dai
proviamo facciamolo insieme quelle
persone che invece di fare soltanto uno
a zero vogliono fare due tre quattro
cinque a zero no e allora queste persone
magari se non ci fossero state queste
realtà sarebbero ancora ferme in un call
center in un fast food e avrebbero
rimandato è ancora rimandato
l'espletazione del loro sapere che la
loro voglia di fare e dunque farmi non
ha finanziato assolutamente nessuno le
persone erano già lì prima che queste
palazzine venissero restaurate le idee e
tecnologie c'erano già e dunque cosa
serve serve sempre qualcuno che possa
incitarti a fare qualcosa ma bisogna
farlo subito che sia la partecipazione
alla campagna di crowdfunding o una
firma
ottenere un progetto che sta nascendo è
dunque quello che tutti noi dobbiamo
fare è ripensare a quella persona che ci
ha chiesto sai voglio fare questo
progetto che ne dici oppure perché non
partecipiamo tutti insieme a questa
campagna di crowd funding per il nostro
comune per aiutarlo a fare qualche cosa
e non rimandare come siamo sempre stati
abituati a meno qui al sud al poi si
vede o si vede poi si vede a rimandare
sempre qualcos'altro perché l'esperienza
che ho vissuto in questo 2015 e che
quando viene data la fiducia la mano
sulla spalla sulla pacca sulla spalla o
qualche altra cosa che ti induca a fare
quello che ritorna a tutti noi è un
qualcosa di un'energia e di un assoluta
grandezza che ci permette tutti insieme
di salire in quella macchina digitando
un'altra data per il futuro e non ce ne
frega assolutamente nulla
se troviamo qualche autovelox perché il
nostro obiettivo è quello di andare
avanti e far progredire sempre tutti
grazie